and that means that maybe ding has to
mix things up and no more english
opening that we saw from him two games
ago
it's back towards the queen's pawn where
we see the queen scan bit what do we
predict here key moment
oh maybe the nimzo
okay no no nimzo for black it's all
about what pragmata chooses here will
black push a pawn in the centre of the
board will black star squad bishop come
out maybe give a check
you can go to the queen's gambit from
this position you can go into the bononi
from this position queen's indian from
this position this is the moment where
you choose and look at pragnanda he's
just looking away from the board he's
choosing what opening to play
he did not expect this but slightly
surprising this is ding's main opening
yeah it is his main opening it's also
quite logical because this is a lot
safer to pick up the
the knight on the right side and then
develop the knight on the left side and
he chooses
something that is i don't know the name
of this what is it called i think it
transposes to a variation of the black
knight tango
where the the knights kind of dance
around for black because they can get
kicked um this black knight that's just
jumped into um onto this c6 square the
white pawn in the center of the board
can actually go and attack it and the
black knights would actually have to do
a bit of a dance
i don't know if that's why it's called
the tango
but the black knights tango normally
starts without black touching any of his
pawns the black knights coming out on
their first two moves
so i'm not sure if it's a direct trans
position but as far as i know that's the
closest
related opening so will this be one of
those other on our opening stats
i think so yeah wow doesn't count as a
queen's gambit because black's pawn is
not in the center of the board
i've never seen a
pride play this i've never seen actually
any player play this on the champions
chess tour
prague that's why he was thinking he was
just trying to surprise ding as quickly
as possible and ding
i don't think he's
spent one minute on any fourth move ever
in the champions chess store normally he
knows his openings inside out so big
surprise
do the players actually can they see
each other or can they choose they can
choose yeah because i think fernando
looked up at the camera looked right
into the camera like as if he was saying
hmm what are you going to
do would be funny if he winked as well
oh yeah
i got some preparation in
that's a
that gives chess players a lot of joy
to get that in okay so meanwhile
yeah some really weird moves i've got to
say from pregnant especially um but
weird is good in this situation remember
he's in a must-win
scenario with black
that means you have to do something a
bit different
you have to surprise the opponent here
white is occupying the center and the
reason i say that this is weird for
black is because look at what he's doing
he's just treading water black is hiding
on his first three ranks not challenging
the white uh the white pawns in the
middle of the board and that's rare
conventional wisdom says you have to
challenge in the center of the board you
have to do something you can't allow
your opponent to control especially with
pawns and now depending on what pregnant
does it's black to play we could see a
direct transposition into the king's
indian
defense except white has won a move
white's pawn
on the a3 square normally that would be
back
um on its starting square okay prague
meanwhile keeping his options open
moving the black rook i don't like this
last move i've got to say
from black i think that black's choices
here are quite limited you have to
develop you have to push one of your
pawns white's center is just too strong
right now yeah and uh the players are
actually still following theory
and uh this move is a little bit unusual
actually because it allows black to make
the following breakthrough and now we
have a very critical moment
you can either step forward with your
pawn or you can capture pawns and i
think bearing in mind what happened to
pragnanda yesterday against giri
do not step forward with the pawn
it's they're too complicated too wild
capture the pawn and it's going to be a
lot more harder for pragananda to
generate winning chances yeah and if if
the black pawn uh well if the pawn
structure had blocked up there would be
no trades it would be so much tension
and as ivanka mentioned you're quite
happy to see this exchange in a
situation where a draw is good for ding
yeah
i mean it's natural isn't it so now he
again there's a choice you know capture
with a pawn capture with a knight i
guess
you know you probably should capture
with the pawn keep as many pieces on the
board as possible the problem is queen
trade might happen and uh a drawish a
drawer kind of
well it will suit ding but okay he does
play this and now i'm not
really uh expecting um ding here to keep
the queens on the board because that
would allow again the situation full of
tension i expect the queens to come off
and they have and in this scenario
white's knight does have a nice outpost
in the center of the wood blacks does
too this is a hole in white's position
for the black knight to jump into later
but
i don't know it's just so balanced white
has no real weaknesses and i'm i'm
slightly surprised i think maybe taking
with the knight keeping the center
closed this would have at least kept
more tension in the position the queens
would remain on the board and still
black is relatively active
but uh okay prague now in this current
position thinking of how to recapture
the queen maybe he wants to take back
with the knight so that at some point he
can push his pawn forward and control
the square that the white knight wants
to jump into
queen's off the board though it's going
to be hard for prague to win this game
ding is just being cynical he said this
in an interview before he said he was
being a bit dirty in his own words just
by trading everything off uh in a
situation where he only needed a draw
well it's allowed you can always be
smart within the rules and i guess it's
going to be a tango game then you know
the player's time going back and forth
it's weird it started as a kind of black
knights tango and then it turned into a
king's indian this looks exactly like a
king's indian position
yeah it's just that pawn structure now
and again the players just using pattern
recognition often openings transform
they change into each other and you just
have to recognize those patterns that's
why it's good to have a vast kind of
knowledge of different chess openings
you can't always play the same thing
every time at this top level then
both sides freestyling but prague
thinking now how to recapture this white
queen and before today prague had played
zero kings indian on the tour with the
black pieces
and ding with white
one yeah
no three three actually and one win one
draw one uh
black win okay oh lost for ding yeah
over the board at least ding is known as
a bit of a king's indian killer he's
normally very good at punishing players
who play the king's indian
ivanka you surprised
by the last few moves yeah slightly
surprised you know i was thinking that
maybe the play would be a bit more
dynamic from pragnanda and
this one looks like such a hard
hard task you know to try to win the
position from this against
ding who is so so strong and we're
talking about like fine margins this is
this is the thing these players are not
going to make huge blunders they're
going to if they're going to blunder
it's going to be small things
and in this type of position a small
blunder is actually not going to cost
the game
and even though we've seen three black
game
well
three games being won by the black
pieces um it's a lot harder to win when
you play with the black pieces if white
just wants to draw it's a lot easier if
white is pushing for a win to
to win aha so it's hard to be in that
must win yeah with the black pieces
definitely
i mean the reason you're right there
heidi completely the reason black won
the first three games is because white
was taking risks taking chances trying
to create uh something out of nothing
and
it rebounded on white in the first three
games today but
this one it's definitely a different uh
philosophy from ding
and okay he brings his bishop out
creating a pin on black's knight and
that white bishop now real nuisance
okay well pregnant he is spending some
time to think he has to win this game
now we do have our selfie challenge
today where you can win a signed
chessboard by anish giri and all the
selfies are coming in so let's take a
look at some of them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
waiting for prank to win was the message
from that final selfie thank you to
everyone we enjoy so much seeing
yourself is and having you
with us while we watch the action and
chessable master is prague fighting so
hard to win this game to tie the first
match in the final he's been thinking
for such a long time now david this must
be very difficult he's been thinking for
a long long time and i think it's
because he's unfamiliar with this type
of opening which we mentioned kind of
reached we reached in a weird kind of
unusual way but it is quite a difficult
position in itself also remember prague
doesn't have to just look for moves he
has to look for moves that keep tension
that pose problems for ding and i think
that's the difficult part i think there
are maybe two or three moves which are
completely fine here for black but
none of them really create those winning
chances that he needs in this game
and yeah now down to eight minutes
already six minutes down on the clock
compared to ding
it's getting critical for prague already
a big big moment yeah and it kind of
almost feels like
just a psychological opening nightmare
for the young indian and well
opening nightmare that is our quiz of
the day
an amazing prize up for grabs it's the
chessable course on the grand rue lopez
by niels grandelius and the elusive
panda says the worst opening for me to
face is black and is the london i know
it's gonna be a long game
sometimes opening does this to you and
uh meanwhile pragananda has actually
made a move so he's moved his rook one
square up the board getting out of the
eyeline of the dark squad bar reacts to
this yeah the bar reacts and the reason
is because it is quite a clumsy move the
rook as uh your micro mentions gets out
of the diagonal of the white bishop but
look at this black bishop suddenly this
black bishop is trapped if you can't
move this black bishop you can't move
your rook in the corner either and it's
all because this pin was just too
frustrating ideally you want to move
your rook in a different direction but
if for example you move it back to the
center then we would see
for example a trade on this square maybe
even actually uh thinking about it the
white knight would come in and start
targeting this pawn if the white knight
gets to this square it will hit not just
one black rook but another black rook in
the corner so black in a way had to play
a move like this or at least prague felt
uh compelled to play this move because
he defends his pawn and okay it was just
a temporary blockage of his own bishop
after the white rook slid across we see
a trade of rooks and
there is some hope for prague for
example in the current position um i
mean i'm assuming that white will take
back with his rook here maybe the white
bishop can actually slide back and
capture and go after this knight that
would be a very ding type of move a very
clever sophisticated idea there but if
for example he plays the most natural
move putting a rook on an open file then
the hope i see here for prague is that
he can bring his bishop out finally this
bishop was blocked and again if he gets
given a move or two then suddenly after
a trade he can establish at least one
good piece in the white half of the
board this is a beautiful outpost for
the black knight anchored by a pawn
at least one good square might lead to
better things later in the game still
takes a long long time to even create
any winning chances for black or even
dream of any winning chances for black
but
i think this is what he has to go for
wow
and uh it's looking good for dingley ran
in game four here let's head back to
simon at the good night who are they
cheering for the norwegian down at the
pub tonight simon
and to be totally honest i think they're
enjoying themselves too much uh to be
having a look so much at the screen
we've got the games up here on the big
screen but look how
everyone is just playing blitz and
having a good time here so everyone say
hello you're on tv
so um
hi hello hello
okay that was that was very calm hello
but anyway we're uh yeah we go through
now and we'll check out some other
people in the in the bar so we'll walk
this way
and um well how i mean prague is doing
uh well but black's been winning every
game so far got some serious beard envy
going on over there that beard is
fantastic well done there
but we'll just walk along here and um
well let's ask this chap here um about
the candidates because obviously this is
the big event coming up yeah and um one
of the players will be in the candidates
fighting for the world championships do
you think it could be ding or you got
someone else on your mind uh
if you're sure or someone
you think
foreign yeah
okay well maybe frugia because if
ferugia does it that means magnus carson
will actually play which will be
fantastic but at the moment back to the
studio in a second because it is
obviously prague who needs to win this
game to give himself a chance in this
leg
he definitely does simon thank you so
much that looks like a very good time at
the good night and dingleran world
number two that must be a motivation for
magnus as well if ding is the one that
wins the candidates we did have a couple
of moves this is the looking very hard
for prague to win this it's still going
to be difficult purely because there
have been so many exchanges so far a set
of queens a set of rooks already off the
board but
still enough sufficient ammunition later
to create some imbalance still that hole
that we talked about on the d4 square
for black's knight to jump into
some hope for prec the bar says 0.3
advantage for for ding i have to say hi
date so the bar for me as a beginner in
chess is
my reference to understanding what is
going on on the board and it's something
we copied from nrk the show that you
have been working on for many many years
since magnus became world champion what
do you think is
the the
key to making chess understandable for
non-chess players i think it's just what
you're saying that to sort of tell the
viewers
who is better off because it's so
difficult to look at the board and and
realize um if you especially if you
don't know a lot of chess and even
people at my level it's probably easier
for you but i think for everyone it
helps just to have the bar to kind of
understand a little bit
and the norwegian views they love they
love the bar yeah it's um
yeah look at the bar and we even had a
viewer um who who tattooed look at the
bar on her arm really yeah it's like the
best tattoo it's a part of it like a
bigger chest tattoo but it's uh it's
cool oh that's a challenge for our
viewers
anyone tattoo look at the bar
[Laughter]
i say it a lot because again it is my
only reference to understanding you know
is is the score now one nil if you
reference to football is it five nil you
know is it nil nil what is the score
here simon loves the bar too maybe you
should just get them
it works very well in english as well of
course with uh
you know simon being at the good night
bar
all the time and yeah you mentioned
heidi the bar but i mean it's useful for
us too i mean often we're looking at a
position and even though we're
decent players i mean even if there are
big blunders we won't necessarily see it
unless we see the evaluation bar swing
it's only having that kind of hint that
the computer gives us that's why we're
able to commentate and uh show some of
these variations often if it was a game
if we're super stressed we wouldn't know
and i mean the players of course they
don't see it they don't know the
evaluation but
i think that's why it's it's quite nice
to kind of see it even as a strong
player my well decent player myself um
it's nice to kind of
see the swings and roundabouts in the
game it makes it more dramatic and
entertaining what is their reaction
among maybe more and we do have more by
the way yeah white's bishop going to the
edge of the board i mentioned the black
knight wants to jump into the center so
ding is trying uh just to eliminate all
chances of losing the game by
eliminating this black knight
talking of the bar though he's not a big
fan of that move slowly but surely maybe
drifting in black's favor
sorry kai you are yeah i was just
wondering uh players your level watching
chess of course they have done for many
many years maybe not as used to having
the bar
are they opposed to it or do they like
it do you think
i think everyone likes it yeah to be
honest with you because it's a really
good indicator as david says you know
whether you know someone is doing well
if there's been a blunder and
like david also highlighted when there's
a blunder it's also this is the moment
where we can go ah okay this is what's
happening
and you start looking and trying to
calculate and that is so handy i mean it
would be kind of cool if they introduced
chess with the bar
just the bar yeah how much would that
change
the game at this top level i think it
would change a lot because
sometimes when you sit and play and also
like in all levels because when you sit
on plane you look at a move and then you
think
is it going to work if you have the bar
then you know there's at least something
that that works if it's like a big
advantage for your
for you
it means that blunders would almost
always be punished yeah yeah often a
blunder would happen and if you don't
see the bar you just trust your opponent
you just assume there's nothing there
but if you see your opponent makes a
strange move and suddenly the bar goes
in your favor you're like oh yeah that's
the moment yeah
the the perfect example from from the
match in 2014 right in game six was it
when when magnus made a blunder but
anand didn't discover it and with the
bar he probably would have yeah
definitely and that was so uh um because
i think that showed like the the gay
miners played because you couldn't tell
and tell at all that he made it blunder
except that he stopped writing with his
pen his hand just stopped and that was
all all the signs that he gave no no did
not uh that must have been a tense
moment in the nrk studio in 2014 bunch
of moves any hope for prague definitely
hope for prague because the position is
changing i'm not sure whose favorite it
is in but as long as there are
imbalances i think that will make prague
fans very very happy and here we go
prague does have the bishop pair let's
jump in to show what has just happened
um we left it here just a few moments
ago we mentioned that black was actually
trying to remove the white knight just
so the black knight could jump into the
center of the board and uh ding said
okay you can remove my knight but i'm
actually going to go and double your
pawn structure and remove your strong
knight potentially prague decided okay
you can do that but uh okay rerouting
his knight first of all we saw a trade
in the center of the board and now
white's knight stepping back but it's
all about the different kind of um
selection here of minor pieces black has
the two bishops and position is
relatively open i can imagine this
bishop being very strong tying down
white's pieces to this pawn and the
other black bishop does have a future as
well at the moment staring at its own
pawn not great but if you look at the
route for this bishop you could step
back
round and into the center of the board
and it does take a few moves but
definite potential behind black's pieces
also this knight which is on the edge of
the board
it's on the rim it's a very dim piece
right now it's about to leap forward
into the center adding extra pressure
onto this pawn there's a lot of kind of
built up uh pen top pressure um
that is going to come on the white
position from uh from the black minor
pieces but it is however a double edged
position because the weakness of these
pawns might become a factor later on and
ding was trying to remind prague of his
pawns dropping his bishop back hitting
this guy but prior says okay i don't
care i'm stepping forward
actually it's quite hard to attack these
pawns in the short term so that is one
uh another factor on prague's side on
ding's side however of course it's not
just the pawns but the weaknesses of the
squares in front of them and this knight
is headed towards an outpost it's in
balance now though it's not a dead
position and that was my fear earlier
that ding would just swap before the
pieces
get rid of all the winning chances and
just eliminate any hope but there is
hope
um it might not be a big big kind of
attack here for prague but as long as he
can keep the game alive he will have
chances
okay
good news for all the prague fans in
india and all around the world actually
we know he has a huge fan base already
the 16 year old coming from exams
earlier today and now fighting to tie
the match
it's uh dramatic if he
isn't able of course to win but he still
has a match tomorrow and he can still
win that match to take it to tie breaks
it's not over for prague he's definitely
not over and i don't know if he has
exams tomorrow that's the key question
i hope he can get a good night's sleep
we'll have to ask him whether he has
exams
but
oh
does it matter if he has another set of
exams we need to call his teachers yeah
i mean i don't understand why they made
him do it me neither
um okay well we have seen a set of
trades and the black knight has jumped
in to the middle of the board and
well there is a threat in the air knight
takes pawn
yeah there's pluses and minuses to this
decision from prague though i mentioned
that as long as you had the two bishops
you have long term hopes yes you had a
bad pawn structure but practice decided
to trade at one bishop for one of the
knights and if you look at the two
bishops right now that remain on the
board they are of opposite colors white
bishop on the dark squares black's
bishop on the light squares in a way
they'll just kind of pass each other by
and balance each other out ivanka
mentioned it's like ships passing each
other in the night
yeah if the nights disappear i think
it's going to be a draw it's just about
the knights and whether they can survive
yeah i agree but i do like the way that
prague has been playing this particular
position
these last few moves because you know he
has pushed his a pawn alice she's gone
to the fourth row and it restricts
white's pawns on the left
yep so these two white pawns are kind of
just completely immobilized by this one
black pawn
for example if the white pawn ever steps
forward two squares
say in this position then on passant
as if the white pawn had just moved one
square and suddenly everything's going
to drop for white this pawn is a
weakness this pawn is a big weakness and
actually this pawn i think is the key
factor
black's pieces are attacking it white's
pieces are tied down passively defending
and it will come down for example if
black just waits it will come down to a
situation where ding has to decide does
he ever trade off a bishop for a night
if he trades off his bishop for the
black knight then suddenly the black
pawns are no longer doubled and black
will be able to correct his pawn
structure with a very mobile
kind of situation here he can push in
the center here he can push uh over here
just trying to open things up for the
bishop against the knight which prefers
blocked positions and uh okay i was
expecting prague to just slowly wait
improve his king maybe bring it closer
towards the center but he says no he
just steps back kicking away this white
bishop and wherever the bishop goes now
is his idea to bring his knight to this
side of the board is his idea maybe to
just swing his rook to the open file
we'll soon find out but the black pieces
are getting quite active maybe the rook
will come into the white half at some
point
it might come down to a situation where
it's just completely blocked and black
will have to open up the other side of
the board maybe with a pawn push he
needs to play on both flanks here i
think in order to win later prague
yeah i think it's super important that
uh last point that you made about
playing on both sides of the board
and after ding has retreated the bishop
maybe this is something he needs to
consider seriously actually just uh
think ahead and visualize what pragnanda
might be doing and just put a stop to
that idea
um
the former world champion aletari karpov
was famous for doing these type of
things
yeah and another thing that karpov here
i'm thinking another world champion
petrosian would be uh considering here
is for example black just pushing a pawn
just doing not too much and uh the
reason i want to push this pawn just to
solidify my pawn in the center and then
okay he's actually done this and i think
he's got a specific maneuver in mind i
think he wants to push his pawn one
square forward to kick away the white
bishop and when the bishop moves it
looks weird to put your pawns on dart
squares where they're targets but the
whole reason is that you've created a
square in the middle for your knight and
there's actually a clear path for it to
get there the black knight could step
back and back and into the center and
for example if we see this happening on
the board the black knight once it
reaches there it's on a protected
outpost no pawn can ever touch this
knight and if you ever trade off a
bishop for it again these pawns correct
themselves they uh well protected past
pawn here for black and easy targets for
the rook
i think prague has got a really deep
strategic maneuver in mind and therefore
ding of course he spots it and
if we rewind before black gets a chance
to push this pawn ding says no i'm going
to block you off i'm going to control
that square myself
um it has come at the detriment of
white's bishop though white's bishop now
blocked in
prague he's making these big decisions
so quickly jumping to the side with his
knight hoping again for this trade
because i think the black rook now has
more targets than the white rook
but i don't think ding will exchange off
here maybe he'll just bring his king
towards the center
still roughly balanced i have to say you
know despite the position being roughly
balanced i really like what pregnant has
been doing i really like the
sophistication behind all his ideas i
think it's so instructive as well
and uh what the white king stepping
forward joining in the action but what
next that's the problem uh we mentioned
opposite color bishops while knights
remain on the board i don't think it's
such a big factor but now that the
knights have just left the board he's
traded off knights
if the rooks disappear it's a complete
fortress you'll never be able to break
through these bishops just cancel each
other out it's going to be a dead draw
it's all about the rooks now can i keep
them on the board right now white can't
use this open file because the bishop
controls this square so the white rook
is a bit stuck black's rook will get to
the open file but is it enough
i don't think it will be why did he
trade off knights if uh if it goes
towards the draw yeah i
good question heidi i don't really know
i think maybe he just didn't see
anything better but i would rather keep
them on and
even if the black knight wasn't great
i'd rather keep them on the board
uh i agree with you i just don't
don't see what's happening and uh
and look here we go the white rook is
actually about to enter the open line as
well uh for example if we see the black
rook swing across which is maybe even
the best move then we'll just see a
trade and here white will never conquer
the delight squares black will never
conquer the dark squares it's just a
draw prague has to keep the rooks on the
board at all costs now
and okay he does that by pushing a pawn
but
it's not enough it's not enough simply
now it kind of almost feels like white
is better because white has the active
rook i was just like singing pragnando's
praises and then he takes some very
mysterious decision of trading nights
and now i'm like i think it's just draw
and one of the other key things about
opposite color bishop endings alongside
um
that have rooks on them it's all about
control and white has control as well as
an active rook
very very difficult for pragnanda to
to win this
yeah um white's bishop is just going to
protect all of its pawns what pragnanda
needs to do now is somehow open up a
line on the king side on the right half
of the board for the black rook to come
through break through
i don't think ding has to allow that
though i think no matter which pawns you
push is black white will always be able
to block it up
and uh
yeah i mean heidi you mentioned changing
off those black changing off the knights
i think that's another key question for
viewers i mean of all levels when to
exchange pieces
and
sometimes maybe practice comparison the
black knight was on the edge of the
board the white knight was centralized
so it makes sense to exchange but if you
need to win
yeah you need knights on the board
imagine a knight in this position just
hopping around creating some trouble
maybe you're not winning maybe you're
not better even but at least you have
some chance to win the game
do you think ding is feeling confident
now he's gonna get at least the draw he
needs to win the match
he should be feeling confident he won't
relax too early i think that's one of
ding's strengths he's so focused all the
time he very rarely makes those one-move
blunders that we occasionally see from
other
other grandmasters he's so focused but
yeah i mean he's big big favorite now to
get the draw and look at his uh tour
rating just below his face today he has
reached 2 800. i guess with a jaw here
though he will drop down below 2800
still an amazing score yeah closing in
on magnus carlsen yeah he is world
number two
fighting to win the match here we have
another move
yeah the white rook steps back very
logical and black's pawns are coming
not sure where they're going to but they
are advancing at least
do you guys see any chances here at all
for black i don't to be honest any
potential crazy plans
it's uh what film is it was like it's a
miracle
i think it's a i think it's life for
brian yeah
which magnus is a big fan of i love it
yeah yeah big fan of uh monty python
yeah they they follow brian around it's
a miracle
yeah so if that happens now yeah you
have to say that actually if the bar
jumps up for prague
it's going to be a miracle i guess the
last three world champions uh kramnik
anand carlson they're all massive fans
of monty python really fun fact i just
remember being at a dinner once in
london and andy kramnik were just
quoting back jokes at each other and i
was just sat there being like what is
this
so nerdy i can't even picture that are
you a fan too um i am now at the time i
was maybe 18 at the time i hadn't been
educated in the art yeah
so now
whenever we have a prodigy
like prague we'll have to ask by the way
what do you think about monty python
yeah and if he says yes then look out
world champion
and uh what the players are
thinking i do want to show you one quick
tweet which is that's a selfie from lucy
liu who says great chess and commentary
got us through a few tough years now
we're on greener pastures and so are our
lambs peter ivanka judith aneesh levon
magnus jan kaya and david
oh
someone's named lucy named her lambs
after us
oh oh that's like unbelievable sorry i'm
like super sweet i'm super excited thank
you lucy lou for sharing that with us
you got to name the next lamb heidi yes
heidi of simon well simon yeah both of
them and uh when can we come visit our
our name brothers and sisters
yeah whatever that is in the world yeah
wherever it is and uh i'm so excited
about that i've never had anything named
after myself either thank you yeah
very cool definitely
and uh yeah and whilst
the players are still very much deep in
thoughts
pragnanda really doesn't have too much
hope unfortunately we just have to show
maybe why there is almost zero hope at
this point and it's because as well the
black rook is actually stuck i was about
to say it stuck where it is if it goes
too far away if it goes to the other
side of the board the white bishop can
come and target some pawns instead the
black rook
kind of keeps the white bishop honest it
slides across if the white bishop moves
there might be some checks
some annoying ideas but in the current
position white is simply going to wait
nothing is going to change black can't
do anything simply if you push this pawn
forward um
[Music]
sorry if white for example makes a move
if you push this pawn forward white can
firstly just block things up
one open line will not be enough for the
black rook because the king can just
stop any entry squares but more than
that i think actually any winning
attempts pushing a pawn are actually
going to backfire on prague we would
just see a trader pawns and now white is
the one creating a past pawn
um let's i mean i want to say let's
catch up with the current position but
nothing at all is changing here ding is
offering that trade of rooks which we
mentioned would end the game in a draw
instantly if the rooks come off dead
draw we're going to find out is prague
going to try and win or is he just going
to trade rooks and admit that today has
not gone well
oh his webcam is a little off we can see
keeps rooks on the board yeah that's
good but we're gonna see the players
repeat the moves and uh here we go ding
does take the first day
it's over winning two games dingley ran
is the winner of the first match in the
big final we didn't see a big
celebration he immediately left the
computer but i do suspect a little bit
of a celebration of the camera